-Our first guest tonight is
an Academy Award-winning
writer and actor
you know from films such as
"Good Will Hunting,"
"The Martian,"
and "Ford v. Ferrari."
He both produces
and stars in "Air,"
which is in theaters now.
Let's take a look.
-I'm willing to bet
my career on Michael Jordan.
-Come on, man.
-You asked me what I do here.
This is what I do.
I find you players,
and I [bleep] feel it this time.
Okay, it's risky.
When you were selling sneakers
out of the back of
your Plymouth, that was risky.
It took balls.
I mean, that's why
we're all here.
Don't change that now.
Phil, I mean,
if you look at him,
if you really look at Jordan
like I did,
you're going to see
exactly what I see.
-Which is what?
-The most competitive guy
I have ever seen.
He is a [bleep] killer.
-Please welcome to the show
Matt Damon, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
I'm so happy you're here.
-It's good to be here.
-How are you?
-I'm doing really well.
I really enjoyed this film.
It looked like it was
a lot of fun to make.
Obviously, you're collaborating
with people
you've been working
with over the years.
And a really nice wardrobe
for you.
Just a solid '80s wardrobe.
-Yeah, I got a
shout-out to Charlese,
our costume designer.
She crushed it.
In fact, the guy that I play
is a real guy, Sonny Vaccaro.
And when Sonny came to the set
to visit with his wife,
she looked at what I was wearing
and she turned to Charlese,
our costume designer, and said,
"It's like you
broke into his closet."
So that's about the
highest praise you can get.
-Absolutely. Now, I guess, like,
not a lot of '80s clothes
were cool,
but Sonny was definitely
not wearing the coolest
of the era.
-No.
-I don't feel like anybody's
going to watch this movie --
None of the teens are going
to watch this movie and go like,
"I want to dress like Matt Damon
in this movie."
-No. Like, there's those things
that you can get,
like the rider in your contract
where you keep the wardrobe.
Like, this wasn't
one of those jobs.
-Your rider was, "I never want
to see it again."
-Please.
-A lot of beige.
I think you found out
if beige was your color.
-Yeah. We found out that
it's definitely not my color.
But, actually, yeah,
when I showed
a rough cut of the movie
to my wife
and the movie ended,
and I turned it on and I said,
"What'd you think?"
She goes, "That movie's great.
You look awful."
Yeah.
-Very nice.
At least you started
with praise.
-Just two really true
declarative statements.
-Yeah.
-So, this is based on
the team of people,
you know, behind the scenes
who are putting together
the deal for Michael Jordan
to come to Nike,
which changed, obviously, the
future of of basketball shoes.
And I guess it was inspired --
Maybe the writer came up
with the idea
of watching ""The Last Dance,"
which I think everybody did
during those early days
of the pandemic.
-Yeah, yeah.
He -- Alex, the writer,
I think was inspired by that.
And, I mean, we all, you know,
sat and watched
"The Last Dance."
I think that's how
we all spent the first --
-I would have watched it anyway,
but it certainly showed up
at the right time.
-I think I watched it
a lot faster.
-Yeah. I will say this.
I don't think my wife
would have watched it with me
unless it was a pandemic.
-My wife, my kids, like --
Yeah, yeah, exactly.
My COVID bubble.
We all -- We binged it together.
-In the COVID bubble,
did you try to --
I mean, first of all,
I don't know how much
your kids engage with your work.
Do they like watching you?
-Uh...no.
-Yeah. Did you take advantage
of the COVID bubble to say,
"You know, let's go revisit
some of dad's early work?"
-Absolutely not.
-No, they wouldn't stand for it?
-No, I have --
Well, my my 16-year-old
likes to give me a hard time,
and she is very clear
about not wanting to
see anything
that I'm in
if she thinks it might be good.
-Oh, interesting.
-Yeah.
So she'll
watch anything she hears --
Like, if I get bad reviews
in something,
she's like -- That's
the one she wants to see.
-Oh, my God.
-Yeah.
-That is the most ice-cold
16-year-old thing
I've ever heard.
-There's one movie
I did that's not very good,
and it's called
"The Great Wall."
And my daughter was talking
to one of her friends
and she was talking
about this movie.
"My dad did this movie
'The Wall.'"
And she kept
calling it "The Wall."
And I was finally like,
"Isabella, that movie is called
'The Great Wall.'"
And she was like, "Dad, there is
nothing great about that movie."
[ Applause ]
-Okay.
-I like thinking
that she knew for months,
"I'm going to just keep
calling it 'The Wall.'"
just setting you up,
setting you up.
-She's like --
Yeah, like, just like this
for months until I'm like,
"It's not called 'The Wall.'"
Yeah.
-The old-school boxy car phone.
That was a really nice thing
to see in this film.
Do you remember
the first time you saw
someone on the car phone?
-Yeah. In fact,
we put this line in there like,
"I'm calling you on the --
There's a phone in the car."
Like, he's really
excited about it,
because we remembered when --
you know, in the '80s,
when we first saw a car phone,
and it was like, "Wow!
Like, that car
has a phone in it."
It's like the craziest idea.
-I think most of those
early calls were just people
telling them they were
calling them from a car.
-You know what?
Actually, Ben and I
had a roommate for a summer
in California in 19--
I want to say '90, '91, maybe.
And this kid,
he couldn't afford a car phone.
He bought a plastic phone.
This is a true story.
Bought a plastic phone
and would --
at red lights,
would put it up to his ear
with, like,
a cord going to nothing.
And that was his attempt
to try to, like,
pick up women,
like, at stoplights,
because it was
such a rare thing.
-I mean, it definitely seems
like he didn't plan for whatever
Step 2 was.
-No. Like, can you imagine?
"Can I borrow your phone
for a second?
I got to make a call."
-"Oh, no!"
-Yeah.
"I'm out. I'm out. I'm out."
-"You ask too many questions."
-Yeah. Yeah.
-We had a your co-star
Jason Bateman here,
and we were talking
about the '80s.
And Jason was admitting that he
kind of crushed the '80s.
Like, he had
a really good decade.
You were mentioning L.A. with
Ben in the early '90s.
Obviously, you know, the '90s
eventually worked out
pretty well for you guys.
But how were the '80s and '90s
for you as far as
fashion, hair,
just a general vibe?
-We did not crush the 80s?
-No, you didn't? Yeah.
-We did not.
We did not crush the '80s.
Up to the mid-'90s,
we were struggling.
Yeah, we weren't
crushing anything.
Bateman was dominating.
That's true. Yeah.
Yeah, Bateman -- I can see how
he loved those years.
We were not.
-Yeah.
Do you feel like --
Do you ever look back --
I have this, I think,
very false sense of myself
through the '80s,
which is, I don't think
I wore the worst fashion,
forgetting that
even like a middle-tier
bad choice looks awful now.
-Yeah. I don't think I wore
anything that looked good.
Like, I haven't seen
a good picture of me in the '80s
or really, you know,
until about 1996.
Like, until people start--
professional people
started dressing me for movies.
-Yeah, right.
-Yeah, yeah.
-Like, someone who knows
what they're doing
comes over with a comb
and is like,
"I'm about to fix everything."
-"You need to put this on and
you need to ask no questions."
And -- Yeah.
-I feel like every
almost-good picture
I see of myself in that era,
like, one thing will ruin it.
It's like,
"Oh, hardcore pleated pants."
-Right.
-Just like...
-Yeah. Oh, my God. Yeah.
I'm thinking back
to my prom picture.
Yeah, there's not --
I don't think I --
-It wasn't a good era.
We didn't grow up in a good era.
-It was not strong.
It was not -- But I feel like we
represented it well
in the movie.
-You really did.
I should stress, you --
And it was a lot of nostalgia.
Obviously, we both --
we're Boston sports fans.
M.J. is someone that you could
watch and have appreciation for,
but at the same time,
you know, he --
You know, I was rooting against
him for most of his career.
-Yeah.
-Did you see him play live?
-I did, yeah.
I did because my dad had tickets
through his work
that we could go
to one game a year.
And. obviously,
Boston in the '80s,
it was Celtics-Lakers that --
So Lakers tickets
were not offered.
They were off the table.
That was those were for clients.
They were like,
"Any other game you can go to."
And so my brother and I
would always want to go see M.J.
just to say that we saw him
live, because it was --
You know, I mean, he just
kind of transcended the game.
He was -- It was
just so exciting to watch him.
And then, of course,
like, they became kind of
America's team
because the national game
every week was the Bulls.
And, you know, he was just
kind of bigger than the game.
-I mentioned
we were Red Sox fans.
You were very kind.
This was, I think, the beginning
of my second season.
You hosted the season
premiere of "SNL."
You were kind enough
to do something.
Look at -- We are the same.
We did not age.
We did not age at all.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Wow!
Wow!
-You know what?
Do you remember,
in the beginning of
the "Captain America" movie,
they, like, -- They use,
like, digital effects
to make Chris Evans look like
a smaller version of himself?
I feel like I'm
the smaller version here.
That's, like -- That's before
the super serum.
-That's amazing.
-Do you -- That was --
So, that's 2002 that you hosted.
-Yeah.
-Do you remember, like, getting
the call to be asked to do that?
I mean, obviously, you're pretty
established in your career
at that point.
-Yeah. You know,
what was funny about that
was I actually --
My agent, Patrick,
who's been my agent for
30 years,
called me up and goes,
"You're hosting
'Saturday Night Live.'
You know,
it's the season opener."
And I was like, "Yeah, great."
I was like,
"But I'm not promoting anything.
I don't have any --"
And he goes,
"No, no, no, of course."
"Bruce Springsteen's
the musical guest."
So I was like,
"Oh, yeah, of course."
So, like, we're big fans
of Springsteen.
So, like, just we --
I basically hosted the show
so that I could go
watch him do the two songs.
-Not a bad play.
-No, not at all.
I had a great time.
I really -- I loved it.
But I didn't host it
for another 16 years after that.
-Well, man, it is just so nice
to have you here.
It has been far too long.
And the movie's great.
And it's always such a pleasure.
Really appreciate it.
-Thanks, Seth. I appreciate it.
-Matt Damon.
"Air" is in theaters now.
We'll be right back with more
"Late Night."